-Thank you for being here.
You were trending
on Twitter recently, and --
You know what I'm talking about?
-I do, only because --
I mean, if --
when that happens to you,
I feel like it happens to you
more than it happens to me,
but when it happened to me,
I felt like I must have done
something terrible.
-Yeah.
-I immediately reverted
to a 5-year-old, like,
"What did I do?"
-"What'd I do?"
Yeah, "What did I do?"
-"What did they find out?"
-Yeah, "I know It didn't die."
-Yeah, exactly.
I'm still here, so that's good.
-Okay, yeah.
-That's good.
-Yeah.
So what was your take on this?
-Well, my take was,
try to put on the cool face.
"Oh, really? That --
For -- For -- Why?"
-Who let you know?
Who let you know
that you're trending?
-It was one of the grips
on set.
He's like, "Hey, man,
you're trending on Twitter,"
and then he went off to do
his thing, and I was like...
-"My career is over."
-..."I'll be right back."
[ Laughter ]
-But you were trending because
of a very specific scene
that you shot
on "Dawson's Creek"...
-Yeah.
-...many years ago.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
-Someone tweeted about it
and was very confused.
We actually have the clip.
Let's take a look.
-I said check it, Oompa-Loompa.
God...
Hey, ladies, I really love
what you did
with that last cheer.
-Ohh!
[ Audience groans ]
Oh! [ Laughs ]
-I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, now...
-Damn.
-Does the ball hit the camera
after it hit your face?
-The ball hit the camera
after it hit my face,
and they loved it so much
that they --
I think we did two or three
more takes, is my recollection.
[ Laughter ]
Somebody had some issues they
were trying to work out with me.
-Now, was it
supposed to do that?
-Never supposed to do that.
And then here's --
So, you know,
Twitter has its ups and downs,
but one of the things
I love about Twitter
is, man, people get into it.
So when I did finally
get back to my trailer,
I realized I hadn't screwed up
and I wasn't dead,
my career wasn't over --
all good things,
there's like a forensic analysis
of this 25-year-old TV show.
"It was CG."
Someone's going frame by frame,
"Well, you can see he dodged
the ball at the wrong time,
so the ball's not --"
This was just a beach ball
painted to look like
a basketball
that got bounced off my face.
-That's...
There you go.
That's the trick.
So it didn't hurt.
-I mean, it didn't feel great.
-It didn't feel great, yeah.
-It's not amazing.
-After three takes, like,
"I think we got it, right?"
-And, also, I'm like 19,
so, you know, you're like,
[ Voice breaking ] "I'm fine.
Everything's cool.
Throw it harder, man."
-"Harder.
Use a real basketball
this time, man."
Yeah. You also broke
the Internet again
during this past Halloween.
You were photographed
going to a Halloween party
dressed as Charlie Conway
from "Mighty Ducks."
This is your character.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your character.
Do you keep a Charlie Conway
jersey in your closet?
-Actually, this is my lovely
wife's Charlie Conway jersey
that she keeps in her closet
for occasions such as this.
-But I love that she --
'Cause she always -- she kind of
does this on purpose.
She wears Pacey T-shirts
and stuff.
-Yeah, well, there's
a notorious Pacey T-shirt,
as well, that she has.
That is my face in Ray-Bans
that she cut into a crop top.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm shooting
in Wilmington right now,
and the first day I was working
when she got in
and I come back home,
and she's like,
"Don't worry. I'm just
at Target, grabbing some stuff."
And I come home, and she's her
in the crop top Pacey shirt.
And I'm like, "Babe,
you can't wear that here."
[ Laughter ]
"Like, not here."
-Yeah, there.
She can do whatever she wants.
Did people freak
when they saw the costume?
-Yeah, the -- Well, this is
super name-dropping,
but I found out something
very important.
Margot Robbie,
big "Mighty Ducks" fan.
-Wow!
-She was at that party,
and she was like --
she turned around,
and for the -- the first thing
she saw was the jersey.
She's like, "Oh, my God!
I love that movie."
And then she looked up
and was like,
"Oh, I get it."
[ Laughter ]
-"Really good costume.
Really good.
That's really cool."
I want to talk about
"Fatal Attraction."
-Yes, please.
-That's a big deal, buddy.
This is the TV adaptation
of the hit movie,
but this is told in a
different way than the movie.
-A different way
and a different time.
So, the movie is made
and set in 1987.
Our TV show is is made in 2023
and set in 2008 and 2023,
which mostly gives us
the opportunity --
Well, one, it's TV, right?
So we have more time.
And if you watch the original
movie, it's an amazing film,
but the culture
has moved, right?
There's just some things
that you couldn't get away
with now even if you tried.
So we have the opportunity
to really delve
into this iconic character
of Alex Forrest
and explain a little bit
of, like, why she is
and what made her
into the woman that she is.
And then, on the Dan side,
my character's side,
we have an opportunity
to show, like,
you know, there are consequences
to your actions.
[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah.
You were telling me backstage
that you ran into someone
recently who
was a big fan of how
the "Fatal Attraction" series
turned out.
I know you don't want
to name-drop, but...
-No, I totally
want to name-drop.
-Okay, good.
-I totally --
I'm so happy you brought this up
because I want
everybody on the planet
to know this story.
-Good.
-So...
[ Laughter ]
And it starts name-dropping,
and it only gets worse.
So, I was at the Vanity Fair
Oscar afterparty.
-Yeah. All right.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-That's fine.
A lot of people go to that.
-I was having a --
[ Laughter ]
I was having a conversation
with multi-Oscar nominee
and winner Michelle Williams,
an old friend of mine.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Now we're --
Now we're talking.
-And in the middle
of my conversation,
a woman who works at Paramount+
who is putting on
"Fatal Attraction,"
came up and said,
"You know, the show is great.
Congratulations.
And Steven...
Spielberg..."
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
...who is the producer
of the movie,
"loves it, and congratulations."
And I was like,
"Oh, that's great.
Oh, my God, amazing.
Can't wait."
And then that conversation ends,
and Steven Spielberg
walks across the room
and comes up to me and says,
"Joshua..."
knows my first name.
[ Laughter ]
"...you are amazing
in this show.
You're great. I loved it.
You and Lizzy, you're fantastic.
Your chemistry's incredible."
And he goes on --
I have no idea
how long it was for
because I had
an out-of-body experience.
I didn't really hear
much of what he said.
Then he finishes,
he walks away,
and I had this
terrible moment of, like,
"Oh, my God.
I hope somebody
that I know witnessed that
because nobody's
ever going to believe that."
-No, of course.
-And it turns out my friend Doug
was standing right there,
and he saw my face and went,
"Yeah, yeah, I saw it."
[ Laughter ]
And now you all know.
And now we all know.
And Doug.
-And Doug.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Steven Spielberg's
favorite production,
Joshua Jackson
in "Fatal Attraction."
Take a look at this.
-Idiots.
-I agree.
-I do.
Hi.
-Hi.
-This is Alex...
I forgot your last name.
-Forrest.
-Alex Forrest.
My husband, Dan.
Dan, Alex Forrest.
-No, I know him already.
-Oh.
-From, uh, the criminal courts.
I work in Victim Services.
-Oh.
-That's with Conchita, right?
-Right.
-Wow!
Are you kidding?
[ Both laugh ]
-You were right, Beth.
This place --
I mean, it's -- it's magical.
-Well...
We've been very happy here.
-I can feel it.
The happiness.
-Eee!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Joshua Jackson, everybody!
"Fatal Attraction"
comes to Paramount+ on Sunday.
We'll be right back with
stand-up from Jackie Fabulous.
Come on back.